[Music]
violet Obama dis pilot a young mom but
this it's the Lord's Day pilot to
Bombardier can you see through the
clouds
pilot to Bombardier all is well here the
[ __ ] gate what do you see
you
pilot to Bombardier it's a cloudy day
but hey I was born a [ __ ] cloudy day
this ain't no to me what's happening you
bad [ __ ] uncle Joey what is it
801 in the a.m. Pacific time but I'm
already done were you supposed to be
doing on the Lord's Day heading go to
church that I [ __ ] I'm not the mood to
see those people I'm gonna have my own
church you understand me this is my body
everlasting covenant do this in memory
of me
oh yeah oh yeah this is as good as it
gets still relaxing on the surgery or in
our seven-day program today I'm gonna
get stalled I'm gonna go for a nice walk
and then I got a spot at the store
tonight just to get out there and
training starts tomorrow for the special
being shot on October 15th and Rosemont
Chicago be there or be square two shows
on the Saturday night so if I don't get
it right the first show I got no choice
but to get it right the second show with
a gun to my [ __ ] it that's how we
roll [ __ ] but enough with the
chitty-chat it's the Lord's Day if you
ain't sparking get the [ __ ] down you go
much [ __ ] Joel Osteen and [ __ ]
bully go walk on some [ __ ] shark
balls where the [ __ ] you doing your time
is also joey time on periscope [ __ ]
which means we smoked reason can we see
the devil [ __ ] when we smoking
today what smoking the best
[ __ ] money can buy wedding cake
are you [ __ ] kidding me as a people
something tremendous
those cookies in the backroom perennial
why uncle Joey why you stopped and I bet
you've never fought that now I don't
want to beat in the basement with a
[ __ ] machine gonna not see how God
they can help my hollow yet we've I got
a plan
look at that that's some [ __ ] reef
for the notice is going better I got the
stitches up like I smell bad co2 exhale
you're ready to go knock the police's
bong hit [ __ ] workout today and
that's it it's a beautiful day thank you
for all the well wishes but the calm
breeze going great the antibiotics a
little [ __ ] up you gotta stop and
slide up and eat some yogurts damn copy
a compulsion juice but what the other
[ __ ] do you guys know what you gotta
do
Oklahoma I'm coming to your August
[ __ ] 6th at the Cherokee Casino
[ __ ] Denver August [ __ ] tent that
some [ __ ] who knows what the [ __ ] day
this off it's 12:00 Thursday through
Saturday and then I'm doing I was gonna
pass on that Nashville now but I'm going
to the [ __ ] oddball tour first we
can't open weekend Sebastian gabriel
iglesias come sakura
you [ __ ] kidding me or what I'm just
[ __ ] honored to be a part of these
[ __ ] bubbles
but Joey what's with the [ __ ] him for
a minute
this is it they're not gonna sparked you
living in the dark understand we need to
take water [ __ ] pills you want them
this is the answer all your [ __ ]
Columbus right here this is it I'm gonna
go now all right hang out with the
family
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day nobody gets
their feelings hurt we should start the
day we uncle Joey most people him and
talk to uncle joy because he's doing 24
[ __ ] man but not me we got a nice
relationship I could be helpful like to
be a godfather how to do em anywhere you
are its oceans in between us but that's
not very fun
can you take it all away can you take it
all the way so do you think you deal
with some [ __ ] knife it's like our
songs for days [ __ ] I got a [ __ ]
little track play in the back of my
[ __ ] head music and Joe Cuba playing
this morning in the shower that's not
the police breathing right we wanna do
should we do another bowl the [ __ ]
wedding cake or doing limbo up the fire
what do you [ __ ] stick hmm
wedding cake I mean look the Papa do
does more to get the party started way
around the marijuana icons what a [ __ ]
like where's he's [ __ ] dude do you
guys believe you better count with him
where is he
well this [ __ ] jerk was deep in bed 8
o'clock not even thinking I'm doing this
with Uncle Joe but Uncle Joe is here
[ __ ] Santa to show you you got a
[ __ ] walk the walk understand me
that's why I got you guys you guys keep
me and [ __ ] check I talk [ __ ] and you
got on that set it's all over Joe you
gotta do it better take the surgery I
must abandon ship
I saw those [ __ ] needles but I
thought about you guys messing what if I
[ __ ] bail how they act
you got a second example
understand me and that's it
everything [ __ ] really smother
[ __ ] a day but you know whole life
two three more days I'll be tip-top
Magoo slangin thick and giving out
bubble bum 88 days away from shooting I
[ __ ] smashed the ones that you
[ __ ] guys put together right so let's
it go on siding I shoot the two up for
some breakout man up and if it don't I
don't give a [ __ ] you know like as the
Sun isn't my [ __ ] nut sack
I never want this again you don't need
the sonic living [ __ ] Alaska makes
the difference no blue jelly anyway was
this embarrass I'm [ __ ] stoned we went
deep into the murky waters of the
underworld
now what y'all mighta stick the eighth
notes
keep your eyes open and you know what
the most important then you write today
uncle Joey loves I got love for you
kinda suckish that's right come on come
on let's bump in more my bout me there's
no wrecking we thought we get who does
these type of things anyway may the Lord
be in your heart today
well the [ __ ] is Jesus Satan him
whatever [ __ ] you've been tied me to
judgment but his the Lord's Day
have a good male smoker [ __ ] up with
food put your week together I'll see you
later someplace sometime okay stay black
you got this you got this they can't
take it away from me don't push it again